hier normal wir haben ein bisschen power
und kraft ich jetzt erzählen töten
nein ich muss jetzt noch etwas tut er
ist fast tot
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen pvp
runde und zwar wie o'brien meine erste
folge zusammen mit sieben hallen und der
simon wird euch gleich erklären was du
lieber brand ist weil ich das ja noch
nicht gebracht habe und die sache ist
allerdings auch die daher nun eigentlich
vieles sehen wollt wissen tag und nacht
tag und nacht daran versucht da den
server ihnen wie auf die beine zu
stellen kriegen es allerdings nicht hin
ich hab einen server bei mir auf dem pc
probiert damit herr much dann geht das
bei simons pc nicht dann haben wir
probiert das ganze über seinen server
laufen zu lassen da können wir beide
dann nicht auf connect damit versuchten
von anderen leuten zu machen das shader
hamborn hingekriegt also dass beim das
sind die soundeffekte ja ja es geht
einfach weiter
komm schon zum anfang bevor es losgeht
es gibt 30 und es los persönlich den
hinweisen
hier gibt es klassen ich würde erstmal
keine klasse nehmen weil das besser wenn
du bleibst also scout ist die stadt
lasse dann erkläre ich einfach nicht
aber man kann auch klassen die aussuchen
normalerweise aber erstmal scout dann
kannste als am anfang
so jetzt geht's los
wir sind beide der kev ist hat ein pass
- der ist jetzt ziemlich gut
bleib bei mir bleibt bei mir wo bist du
wirst du ja reden auch wenn da lang
genauer lang alles was geht befindet
auch wenn es zu reden dann werde ich
wenig trainiert auch mal zu sehen welche
erklärt wie's geht
okay okay was auch der kev ist jetzt
gerade der european cities auch ein
youtube ich habe mir vorbeikommen kann
ich nicht stehen bleiben wegen bleiben
kommt damit also ist unsichtbar und er
ist auch schnell jetzt hat doppelt so
viel wie wir ja und tötet alle leute
gerade rosig ist wie stern alles und wir
müssen drei schwarz das sind sie so sehr
spitze weg bringen der berliner typ hat
rat ein
und er musste jetzt noch mit dem hat
noch da hier mehr er hat eine müssen zum
mitbringen wenn wir drei weg gebracht
haben wird den rhein zu menschen und wir
können ihn sehen und dann gleich töten
wir können ihn auch jetzt schon töten
während unsichtbar ist aber er wird also
ist jetzt noch zu stark und er wird
immer pro weg gebrachten start immer
schwächer ok das heißt wenn der erste
weg geräumt ist habe ich eine chance
sind sogar ist ja dann auch einfach die
luft dann auch richtig tötet und ja
alles weg alles weg doch weg noch bist
du noch am leben was wir dafür natürlich
bist du gard weg da ja ich bin ja der
staat muss auf den blitz warten und der
stadtrat will also der komplette sagen
wo der king kommt das ist gerade ein
bisschen wir müssen gerade ein bisschen
stress machen wir sozusagen weil der opa
hat jemand ist der spiel kann also
selbst definiere ich heute ganz schön
aufgenommen pokemon kracht und wir haben
ja das ist das ist der dass der kev
derart hoch und auf seinem kanal als
projekt laufen hat ja auf jeden fall
ich bin jetzt genau beim beim start
dinge aber ist das wieder woanders
genau das wolle man zufällig also wir
sind gewählt worden
ja ich will vergiftet kontakt habe mich
fit ich bin giftig muss erklärt gibbs
und werdet euch jetzt angreift doch auch
weg ich bin auch nicht wirklich lustig
euro höhere komisches also ich jetzt
sterben
von conny ich heute habe ich das mal
ganz kurz
ja okay ich werde euch das mal ganz kurz
erklären hier das spielprinzip als das
gar nicht richtig mitbekommen habt als
es von anfang an hier breit und dann die
ganz anderen leute hier nochmal wir
haben ein bisschen power und der
brandklasse dich jetzt erzählen töten
nein ich muss ja hat jetzt noch der
etwas tut er ist fast tot alter komplize
total leben habt ihr eine chance
du musst mit ihm das noch ein mitspieler
das noch ein mitspieler alleine hast du
keine chance
es wird ja er würde ich mal hin jetzt
schlagen soll ok 11 conny buß der letzte
und was kann also alleine kann man
nichts machen
nicht ein bisschen zum zu äußern
der ist erst wenn du drei weg über tanz
und es fehlt noch ein schreiner und wo
ist der start der start ist ja der
müsste den kompass muss
doch ist auch unmöglich alleine gegen
heroin zu besiegen
die schale ist übrigens links von dir
müsstest du jetzt dann links runter
unterlaufen das schafft es auch nicht
mehr
danke mach mal finale sichtbar
das coni einen weg bringen der ist nicht
der ist nicht gut in pvp ok-chef lässt
den weg bringen denn der lässt sich am
leben also bringen jetzt ist er schaut
ist jetzt du musst jetzt da genau daraus
und jetzt über den weg ihr über den weg
ihr hier genau was auf conny dazu dazu
ich habe noch darf ja auch wenn die mit
ein bisschen das offen
da muss jetzt was auf der cap war es
nicht wenn er sichtbar ist hat er so
schnell du musst nur drei mal schlagen
ist tot und opfer heißt jetzt erstmal
ganz gut dass das team das derzeit die
langsam geht das jetzt heißt die einem
außenumsatz nicht wissen was geht die
außen rum ist so conny falsch da lang
hat das noch spielt ein bisschen
rücksicht
er hat keine ahnung was er machen muss
connys der orientiert okay er weil er
weiß nicht dass er allen charts weg
bringen muss ich meinen ersetzen du
musst jetzt auf den schatz nehmen und
dann muss ich da drauf klicken und dann
gesehen
ja das ist jetzt auch komplette töten
weg ist dann weg wenn er kommt er wird
jetzt kommen er ist genauer schneller
als du das heißt du siehst ja gehen auf
heile nein nein du kannst du aber nicht
früher gestorben als ich ja ja aber er
hat man es einfach schwer gegen den aber
war auf jeden fall lustig die runde
ich weiß jetzt neun minuten ihr könnt ja
mal in die kommentare schreiben wenn es
euch gefallen hat und der conny meyne
runde als als juror bei machen möchte
soll also dass er mal der böse sein soll
schreibt sie die kommentare schreibt
einfach unter connys video einfach nur
hier oben und wenn ihr meine videos
schaut gerade dann schreibt uns an
meinen will einfach kloster einfach nur
weil es keinen sinn hat es einfach oder
alt das zeigt uns auch dass jetzt immer
noch dabei sein sagte ich mir jetzt noch
mal ganz kurz auf das thema vize bis
zurück zu kommen
da habe ich dann das alles nur ganz kurz
zusammengefasst also die sache ist
einfach diaz kam jetzt längere zeit eine
woche oder zwei wochen oder so kein
titel ist ganz einfach weil ich am
anfang mai hört man gelöscht hat es war
mein fehler allerdings ist zurzeit für
uns so schwer einfachen server
aufzustellen ich verstehe gar nicht
warum weil der server funktioniert wenn
ich ihnen heute komme ich drauf wenn wir
nur allerdings auf den server hosten
geht das irgendwie nicht wir müssen noch
mal mit dem maurice beziehen sie den
räten das sind ein paar leute zwei leute
die kennt sich damit auch aus mit simon
hat zu den kontakt und da müssen wir
dann ganz einfach jetzt in zukunft
schauen wie wir das machen und die sache
ist dann auch ganz einfach die dass wir
das ganze halt irgendwie gehostet
kriegen müssen
und also er macht als bitte kein stress
wir wie wir setzen wirklich alles daran
dass wieder dass das irgendwie
funktioniert also wir ihnen ihr braucht
das gleiche wie heute beschäftigen sich
doch mal hier donald und damit also sind
ja echt pausenlos amrum war
amrum werkeln wieder wir das ganze denn
aufbauen können und wir denken uns recht
lösungen aus versuchen dann da irgendwie
das irgendwie aufzubauen und wir sind
jetzt auch schon auf mein treffer
umgestiegen ich bin oft wird dabei die
schäden die zu installieren also der
beschäftigung sei wirklich tagtäglich
mit es ist allerdings für uns
unglaublich spass und server
aufzustellen
ach ja stimmt weil das ist halt einfach
irgendwie ist ein bisschen kompliziert
auf jeden fall
wir versuchen hinzukriegen falls es
morgen klappen sollte übermorgen spitze
reiste sich im kopf abspielen werden
halt andere videos bringen ihr werdet
schon irgendwie nicht er wer die wäsche
unterhalten werden und so bald
wiederkommt kommt es wird nicht länger
als noch also nicht länger als noch eine
woche dauern also spätestens bis zum
nächsten wochen läuft das ding und ihr
habt ein bisschen erstellen ist uns
einfach weil wir haben mit server
technik und sowas nicht so die mega
planung konnte schon viel besser
mit apache nicht funktioniert allerdings
wird noch bis morgen werden wir direkt
wieder versuchen also monaten ja da habe
ich denn das wird bei aller werdet keine
zeit das internet
wir probieren das einfach dienstag
normal dann danske simon dann versuchen
hinzukriegen dann geht dann auch mit
haben matschie denke ich oder ich hoffe
es wird klappen weil ja normal wird
jetzt auch immer geklappt und wir
kriegen es auf jeden fall hinter geben
unser bestes leute von uns angeboten und
dauern wenn sie euch gefallen hat die
sony roberti mehr wollt dann schreibt
die kommentare hier am rhein oder halt
einfach das video auch bei simon
aufgenommen und will ich sagen jetzt
bald weiter mit fiete wies bisschen
meint craig leute dann bis zum nächsten
mal